Sports journalist
Grant Wahl said in recent tragi
Shocked. All of us.
Shocked, everyone,
shocked the sports world.
The 49 year old died Friday
after collapsing
while covering the World Cup in
The circumstances around his dea
still unclear.
And now his widow, Dr.
Celine Gounder,
is remembering her husband
and revealing how he died.
Listen to her
I think for him, soccer was more
than just a sport.
It was this thing that connected
around the world.
There's so much about the cultur
the politics of sport, of soccer
To him,
it was a way of
really understanding people
and where they're coming from.
I want people to remember him
as this kind, generous person
who was really dedicated
to social justice.
You know,
I think that's another aspect of
that was really important to him
promoting the women's game.
You know, the recent statements
he had made about LGBT
rights that was that was Grant.
That was Grant.
So he had an
autopsy done
here in New York by the New York
medical examiner's office,
and it
showed that he had an aortic ane
that ruptured means well.
Okay.
So aorta,
that's the big blood vessel
that comes out of your heart,
sort of the trunk
of all the blood vessels
and an aneurysm is a ballooning
blood vessel wall.
And so it's weak
and it's just one of these thing
that had been likely brewing for
And for whatever reason, it happ
at this point in time.
Let's bring in CNN
medical correspondent Dr. Sanjay
It is
as John said,
I mean,
just hard to have the strength
to come on and to speak about he
husband.
Can you help us understand
what happened to him now that sh
told the world
Yeah, it's it's so sad.
And, you know,
Grant was one of these people
who I also would communicate
with from time to time via Twitt
And he was just
I got so many texts about him.
But what Celine,
who was a medical
contributor to CNN as well,
what she was talking about
was the major blood vessel
called the aorta leaves the hear
and then gives off tributaries
to all these other organs in the
Sometimes that blood vessel itse
I don't know if we have an image
but it can actually start to wea
It's made up of all these layers
and some of the layers of weaken
So it actually
instead of being sort of
you see that sort of
in the middle of the screen,
that candy cane looking structur
instead of being normal sort of
like that,
will actually start to get
a bullet
and become the shape of a balloo
And that balloon is weaker as th
sort of distend.
The walls become weaker as well.
And with time,
it can rupture,
meaning that those walls
can actually break apart
or you can get blood
that actually dissects
through the walls of the aorta.
Either way,
it can be a catastrophic problem
I will say that it's it's pretty
It typically happens
in people who are older,
and there's really not some sort
that he probably knew that he ha
And thus he was had a family his
or was being screened for some r
It is likely he didn't know this
From what I understand,
he was having bats that he thoug
They were upper respiratory symp
He thought he had bronchitis.
And sometimes that ballooning
can become so large,
it can actually start
to push
and other things
in that part of your body in the
So people may develop
cough or weakness of voice
and things like that.
And it's a totally different pro
Before we run on time. I just so
I just want to
because I want to make sure
you get this in.
People at home who are watching
and I keep looking at the pictur
of Celine and Grant playing it.
It's just devastating.
Is there anything
can you go to the doctor? Can yo
Is there a check up?
Is there
is there any way to know
about something like this?
There is.
I mean, you can be
screened for this sort of thing,
you know, with with imaging test
and things like that.
But the thing is that it's so ra
that it's not recommended
that people go out and get scree
About 20% of the time
there is a family history.
So if you have family history of
then that's something that you s
potentially get checked out.
And you can do that with imaging
I will point out, you know, one
one of the first stories I cover
at CNN back in
2003 was actually the story
of John Ritter dying.
He was 54 years old.
Remember John Ritter?
And he basically had the same pr
He was a few years
older than Grant is now.
But basically the same problem.
They thought it was a heart atta
Initially, they weren't sure.
Ended up being an aortic aneurys
that had dissected similar
to what Celine was describing.
Again, that's rare.
So screening
tests are not recommended
across the board.
But, you know, obviously, these
sad stories like this do happen.
Thank you.
Thank you, Doctor. Appreciate it
And I know.
Got it.
Celine watches, does she texts.
So we're thinking about you.
So we're so, so sorry. Absolutel